the reason i'm upset about this one
is because i know i'm not going to be
able to marry him and honestly it hurts
me to the core
because damn papa he a rare breed no
comparing
like chris lizzo drunkenly slid into
chris evans dms
and his response well it's good as hell
i'm feeling good as hell it all started
over the weekend when the 32 year old
grammy winner posted
this tick tock video using an audio clip
from tick tock star tatiana mitchell
the reason i'm upset about this one is
because
i know i'm not going to be able to marry
him and honestly it hurts me to the
court
because damn papa he a rare breed no
comparing
like chris yeah lizzo shared a
screenshot of the dm
she sent the 39 year old captain america
star featuring a gust of wind
a female basketball player and a
basketball emoji
which fans suspect translates to lizzo
shooting her shot with the hollywood
heartthrob
now here's the t the caption don't drink
and dm
kids for legal purposes this is a joke
i'm like damn this is a big deal pretty
great right
well it gets even better because chris
he responded to the dm and subsequent
tick tock
and lizzo she shared it in a second
video
the reason i'm upset about this one
is because i know i'm not going to be
able to marry him and honestly it hurts
me to the core
because damn papa he a rare breed no
comparing
like chris yeah he responded to lizzo
writing
no shame in a drunk dm god knows i've
done worse on this app
lol it it shook me up
yeah so the knives outstar just might be
referencing the time he accidentally
leaked a
nude photo of his manhood on his insta
story in september
something he later opened up about on
the tamron hall show
look it was it was uh an interesting
weekend
full of uh blessings learned a lot of
typical moments
um you know you know things happen it's
embarrassing you got to roll with the
punches
i will say i have some pretty some
pretty fantastic fans who really came to
my support yes they did
really really nice but back to lizzo she
opened up to et in 2019 about dating
and why she thinks it makes sense for
celebrities to date each other
i think it is hard to understand what
it's like to
have a connection with somebody outside
of all of this these people and famous
people
connect with millions of people at a
time and everybody
is in love with him and everybody wants
you everybody want to smash everybody
want to be your best friend
so it's like really hard to kind of
siphon through like
the bull find the real people but i mean
even famous people can be [ __ ]
so i don't know i might just have to
marry myself again
we just keep it pushing like